MARISA MCCLELLAN: My
name is Marisa McClellan,
and I write a blog
called "Food in Jars."
And my first book was
called "Food in Jars"
and came out about
two years ago.
And then this new book has been
out for just about three months
now and is called
"Preserving by the Pint."
And what I really like about
this book --I mean, granted,
I like it, I wrote it--
is that every recipe in it
starts with either a
pint, a quart, or a pound
or two of produce, which makes
it really great for people
who live in urban areas.
I live in Philadelphia, in
Center City, Philadelphia,
on the 20th floor
of a high-rise.
And so this book was
born out of my need
to continue to can while not
filling my apartment from floor
to ceiling with jars.
Although, doing what I do, it's
pretty much wall-to-wall jars
as it is.
I have a very tolerant husband
when it comes to mason jars.
He has a lot of LEGOs,
so we balance out.
[LAUGHTER]
What's nice about this
book is that so often, when
you read canning recipes, it'll
say you need a flat, or five
pounds, or a very large quantity
of produce just to get started.
Whereas, what I
did with this book
is that I started
picking up the quantities
that you get at farmer's
markets or in a CSA share,
or at the grocery store,
or what you're getting out
of a small backyard garden,
or at a community garden.
And try to build recipes
around those units of measure,
so that instead of needing
that flat or that five pounds,
you could start with just a
quart of pickling cucumbers,
or a quart of
yellow plums, which
I'm going to make the
yellow plum and vanilla
jam out of the book today.
So these aren't really
true, true yellow plums,
but they're close enough.
So we're going to call
them yellow plums.
I wrote the recipe
originally with shiro plums,
which are these really light,
almost translucent plums, which
are really delicious.
But just about any plum
will work in this recipe.
So let me ask first
off, who are my canners?
Who has canned before?
Anybody?
OK, a few folks.
Who has never canned before?
Who is terrified?
OK.
I have a terrified hand here.
So often, when I do these talks,
these classes, a lot of people
come who really are
interested in canning,
but they are sort
of afraid that they
are going to make
a batch of jam,
or do a couple jars of
pickles, and share them
with their friends and family,
and two weeks later, they're
not going to have any
friends and family left.
Right?
That's the fear, that you're
going to kill everyone
with your canning, because
this is the United States.
We are very food safety-anxious.
And it is true that
botulism, which
is the thing everyone's
scared of, is problematic.
You don't want to get botulism.
The good news is that it's
really hard to grow botulism
in canning jars and your
home-preserved foods.
And in fact, it is impossible
for most of the things that we
make at home, because when it
comes to dealing with botulism,
trying to avoid its
development in your jars,
botulism cannot grow in
high acid environments.
And just about everything that
we can at home is a high acid
preserve.
And when I talk
about high acid, you
use pH to determine whether
it's high acid or low acid.
So if something has
a pH of 4.6 or below,
that is a high acid preserve.
And you know that
it's a high acid
preserve also, because if the
recipe is telling you to can it
in a boiling water
bath, you can only can
things in a boiling water bath,
canners, that are high in acid
already.
So your jams, and your
pickles, and your chutneys,
and your jellies, and
your tomato products,
although I'm going
to put a mental
asterisk next to
tomatoes, because we're
going to come back
to those in a second.
But all of these
high acid preserves
that can be canned in
a boiling water bath,
it is impossible for botulism
to grow in those environments.
Because botulism-- when
we talk about botulism,
we're talking about
the botulism spores.
So the botulism toxin is
killed at the boiling point.
But those spores are very hardy.
And they take temperatures
of around 235 to 240 degrees
Fahrenheit to be killed.
And at sea level on our
planet in this atmosphere,
we are never going to be able to
boil water beyond 212 degrees.
And then the higher up
in elevation you go,
the lower your
boiling point goes.
And so when you can
something, and you
need to kill off
botulism spores,
or you need to
inhibit their growth,
you either need to make the
environment highly acidic,
so they can't develop.
Or you need to elevate
the temperature in order
to kill them off.
So if you're working with
these high acid preserves,
you don't have to
elevate the temperature,
because the acidic environment
prevents their germination
into the toxin.
But if you do low
acid foods, then you
can get into the whole
pressure canning world.
I always tell people it's
better to sort of walk
before you can run.
So you want to start
getting really comfortable
with canning, do the
boiling water bath,
feel happy and at ease
moving jars of food
in and out of pots
of boiling water.
And then once you feel
really comfortable with that,
you can go, proceed, get
yourself a pressure canner,
and start doing cool things
like homemade flavored beans,
or chicken stock, or vegetable
stock, and stuff like that.
But for now, I like
to start everybody off
with the boiling
water bath process.
How's everybody feel about that?
Feeling good?
Got the science?
You didn't know there was going
to be so much science when
you came to a cooking
demonstration, right?
But I like to get
everybody on the same page,
make sure that everyone feels
comfortable with the safety
part, and then go from there.
So any safety
questions after that?
Everybody's good?
Everybody's happy to be here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if you're making
something with tomatoes,
you [INAUDIBLE] cannot get
botulism [INAUDIBLE] or you
can?
MARISA MCCLELLAN: Yes.
So tomatoes.
So most fruit already
naturally has a pH below 4.6.
Like these plums, the
pH range for plums
is typically like
3.0 to 3.7 or 8.
Tomatoes, we think of tomatoes
as being very high acid.
But actually, because we, as
Americans, have a sweet tooth,
over the last 50
years, tomato growers
have responded to that
by breeding tomatoes that
are lower in acid
than they used to be.
So what we've done is
made a very sweet tomato
that is no longer safe for
canning in a boiling water
canner unless you
do what's called
acidifying the environment.
So anytime you can
tomatoes, you either
add bottled lemon
juice or citric acid
to the preserve to ensure that
the acid levels in the jar
are high enough that the
pH is low enough in order
to prevent any possible botulism
germination from occurring.
And you either use citric
acid or bottled lemon juice,
because they both have
a consistent acidity.
You can't use fresh lemon
juice, because the acidic levels
of lemon juice varies
greatly on a fresh lemon.
But bottled products,
there's a requirement
that they all have a consistent
acidity across every bottle.
So you know that you're
getting the same thing
with every bottle of
bottled lemon juice.
There are also a few other
fruits that you acidify
like that-- figs, white
peaches, and white nectarines,
Asian pears, and then
melons, and mangoes.
So sort of more of the
tropical fruits and things
where they just don't
taste as acidic to you.
If it doesn't
taste as acidic as,
you know, like, a white peach
doesn't taste nearly as acidic
as a yellow peach.
That's your indication
that, huh, this
might not have as much acid.
Maybe I need to boost it
a little to make it safe.
Everybody good?
OK, cool.
So I have chopped up about two
pounds of plums right here.
And I'm going to measure in
approximately about a cup
and a quarter of sugar.
I'm using sort of fancy
organic evaporated cane juice.
It doesn't really matter.
You can use plain
old granulated sugar.
You can use whatever you have.
I've brought this,
because I wasn't
going to tear the bag
while I traveled here
from Philadelphia today.
So it's all about practicality.
I didn't bring a measuring cup.
That was one thing I forgot.
But I'm going to
eyeball it, and it's
going to be about right, because
this is a pound and a half.
And so I'm going to use about
a little more than a third
of the bag.
AUDIENCE: Did you peel them?
MARISA MCCLELLAN:
I didn't peel them.
You never need to peel
plums, because they
are-- if you peel a plum,
they are unbalanced,
because they're sweet on the
inside and tart on the outside.
So if you peel them, you
lose the tart balance.
And so I didn't peel them.
In fact, that's
why these recipes
are so handy is that you
don't have to peel them.
You can just chop them and
mix them with the sugar.
So I've got my sugar in here.
And we're actually
going to let it
sit for just a couple minutes
before I apply the heat.
You never want to apply
heat to undissolved sugar
unless you're trying
to make caramel.
And caramel is
delicious, and I highly
encourage you to make it.
But I don't want to
caramelize the sugar in here,
because once you start
caramelizing sugar,
it's very easy to
start burning it.
And I don't want
this to get burnt.
So I'm just going
to let the fruit sit
with the sugar for
a minute or two.
And the sugar will
start to pull out
the moisture from the fruit.
And then that moisture will
start to dissolve the sugar.
So it will be this nice,
syrupy fruit cocktail
before I apply the heat.
One fun tip.
And I'm also going to add
the juice of half a lemon
here just to help things start
to dissolve a little bit more
and to add more balance to
the fruit and the sugar.
So one nifty thing you can do
at this point is-- for instance,
you go to the farmer's
market, you come home.
You've bought a quart of plums,
and they're a little bit riper
than you thought they were.
Or in the travel from
farmer's market to home,
they got a little bit beat up.
And you're like,
huh, I don't know
if these are going to last
me throughout the week.
So what you can do is
actually chop them up right
at that point, mix
them with the sugar,
and put them in a container, and
put them in the refrigerator,
and just let them sit for
a day or two until you have
time to come back
and make the jam.
It's a really good way to
break up the work of canning,
particularly if you have
busy lives, which I'm just
going to guess
that all of you do.
And so you can chop
up the fruit one day,
and combine it with the sugar,
let it sit for two or three
days, up to two or three
days, in the refrigerator,
and then come back to it the
next-- when you're ready to can
it up, make the
jam, and can it up.
And so it's a good way
to sort of say, OK,
I'm going to touch
it this day, and I'm
gong to touch it
that day, but I don't
have to dedicate a
lot of time to this.
Although, you're going to see,
this doesn't take that long.
It took me all of 10
minutes to cut up the fruit.
And then once we apply
the heat to this,
this jam is going to cook
in about 12 to 15 minutes,
maybe a little longer.
I often demo on induction
burners, which are amazing,
because they offer such direct
heat and they cook really fast.
So it's a very
handy fuel source.
Any questions about
all this so far?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is it
advantageous to leave it
in the refrigerator for a while?
MARISA MCCLELLAN:
What it simply does
is that it helps pull
out all the syrup.
So you're sort of at that
syrupy, ready-to-cook time
faster.
So you might shave two or three
minutes off the cooking time
if you let it macerate
for a day or two.
Or even an hour, you'll
get that syrupy effect.
Anybody else?
All right.
Cool.
Oh, yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Is it possible
to use less sugar if you
want it less sweet? [INAUDIBLE].
MARISA MCCLELLAN: I was actually
just about to talk about that,
so that's the perfect question.
So when it comes to
canning, making a preserve
like this-- and this jam is only
going to have four ingredients.
It's plums, sugar, lemon
juice, and a vanilla bean,
which I'll get in
there in just a second.
So sugar doesn't just sweeten.
It's not just playing
a sweetening role.
It's also playing
a role in creating
the consistency of the jam,
and it's also a preservative.
So when you reduce the sugar
in a preserve-- and this
is actually considered a
fairly low-sugar jam recipe
in the context of the
traditional canning canon.
Often, the recipes that
our grandmothers made
would be one part fruit
to one part sugar,
because they were
really just trying
to preserve the fruit
as best they knew how.
And they knew that to be, you
need to use a lot of sugar.
And so over the
years, we've found
that you can get a nice
set with less sugar.
But at a certain point, when
you pull out too much sugar,
it becomes very hard
to get it to thicken
unless you use a low
or no sugar pectin.
And there are some really
good ones out there.
One that I particularly like
is called Pomona's Pectin.
And what's cool about it is--
so what's going to happen
is as we cook this
jam, the water
is going to evaporate
out of the fruit,
and the sugars are
going to concentrate--
both the sugar I added as
well as the sugars that
are natural to the fruit.
And so as they
concentrate, sugar
has this really nifty ability
to change physical consistency
as you heat it.
So as you heat the sugar up
and the water evaporates out
of the pan, you're
going to enable
the sugars to elevate
beyond the boiling point.
And so what we're
going to try to do
is cook them to
around 220 degrees.
And at that point, those
sugars will start to thicken.
And it's actually
known as the gel phase
for sugar, for heating sugar.
And so as that
sugars thickens, it's
going to bond with the pectin
that's natural to the fruit.
And so it reaches that 220 mark.
And because I'm making a
small batch-- you'll notice,
I didn't add any pectin to this.
And some people think,
well, you can't make jam
without additional pectin.
But pectin is actually
the fiber that
holds up the cell walls
of fruits and vegetables.
I'm going to turn this on, so
that we don't-- I don't lose
too much time just
talking without cooking.
So pectin is the
fiber that holds up
the cell walls of
fruits and vegetables.
It exists in all
fruits and vegetables,
and some things have
more of it than others.
So you can always tell whether
something has a lot of pectin
or a little bit of pectin
by its physical consistency.
Because if it's got more
pectin, it's sturdier.
So like a lemon, you can
throw a lemon across the room,
and it still looks like
a lemon when it lands.
It's very sturdy.
Whereas, like this is a
fairly not super-ripe plum.
I could probably chuck this,
and it would still land and look
like a plum.
But if I had a really
ripe peach or something,
and I lobbed it
across the room, peach
puree all over the
greens over there.
So it's just a good way
to tell, does something
have a lot of pectin or a little
bit of pectin by its, sort of,
ability to withstand force.
Another good example
is strawberries
versus blueberries.
When you drop a strawberry,
it is strawberry splatter.
You drop a blueberry,
and it bounces.
So it's ways that you can
tell whether something
has a lot of pectin or
a little bit of pectin
is by how it withstands.
I also like to think of it
like the lunch bag test.
You drop an apple
in your lunch bag,
you walk around for four hours.
That apple is still going to be
edible and look like an apple
when you go back to eat it.
You do that with a pear,
and it's pear pudding.
So again, you can
see how something
has more pectin or
less pectin dependant
on its physical consistency.
So for this preserve, plums
have a fair amount of pectin.
And so what we're doing
with this small batch
is that we're going
to elevate-- and you
notice I'm doing
it in a frying pan.
This is not just that this
was the only pan available.
In fact, they had to
go hunt for this pan.
I was like, I need a
stainless steel pan, please.
And so they went
and hunted for this.
So it's this pan's inaugural
use here at Google.
I feel very honored to be
taking it for its maiden voyage.
I like a frying pan or a
skillet for preserves like this,
because you get a lot of surface
area and very little depth.
And you don't have
high walls on the pan,
preventing the
steam from escaping.
So what's going to
happen is that this
is going to cook up to
a boil really quickly.
We're going to get to that
220 point relatively fast.
And then, we won't have
cooked all the sort of starch,
all of the structure
out of the pectin,
by the time the sugars
get to 220 degrees.
And so they'll bond.
And so this is how you can
get a really nice consistency
for your jam without
any additional pectin,
because we're making
a small batch.
Now, if you wanted to do
this with even less sugar,
you would use a low or no sugar
pectin like Pomona's Pectin.
And Pomona's Pectin is cool.
It's called a
low-methoxyl pectin.
That's kind of its category.
And so instead of needing the
sugar to bond with the pectin
in order to create a set,
when you buy a box of Pomona's
Pectin, it comes with
two packets in it.
One is a little packet that
has calcium powder in it.
And the other one has
pectin powder in it
that is made from dehydrated
lemon and lime peels that
have been dehydrated,
ground, and sifted.
So it's essentially just
a very, very fine powder
of lemon and lime essence.
And with that
pectin, what you do
is you make a solution
with the calcium powder.
And then you add that
solution to your cooking fruit
without any sugar.
And then, once the
fruit has softened,
you add the pectin
powder that has
been stirred into
your sweetener,
whether you're using some
honey, or maple syrup, or sugar,
or coconut sugar,
whatever you're using.
And when the pectin hits the
calcium, sort of spiked fruit,
the pectin and the calcium
bond and create a set.
So it's not ever going
to be quite as, sort of,
luxurious and soft
and sort of-- you
know how when you get sort of
like a good handmade, regularly
sugared jam, it has a little
bit of movement and body
and is kind of spoon-able.
When you use Pomona's
Pectin, it likes
to set up a little
bit more firmly.
And so you get something that's
more like an all-fruit spread
that you can buy at
the grocery store.
But it's a really good way
to create a preserve that
is spreadable and still
delicious with less sugar.
The one thing to know
about Pomona's Pectin
is simply-- oops, I just
lost a-- nobody saw that.
Is that when you take
out a lot of sugar,
you have to compensate for
the flavor someplace else.
So when I make really low
or no sugar preserves,
I like to add a lot of
lemon, or a lot of lime,
or a lot of orange,
something that's very acidic,
so that you are balancing
out the lack of sweetness
with some other bright flavor.
So it's just something
that's good to know
if you want to explore those
low and no sugar preserves,
that you need to compensate with
lots of spice and lots of acid
to create something that's still
going to be balanced and have
a lot of flavor.
All right.
How's everybody doing?
Good?
Any questions?
Doesn't just have
to be about this.
Any food preservation
questions, I'm here for you.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What's the
difference between jam, jelly,
and preserves?
MARISA MCCLELLAN: OK.
That's a really good question.
A jelly is a preserve made
with just fruit juice,
or sometimes not
even fruit juice.
It can be-- like I've known
people who make beer jellies.
But it's essentially
a liquid that
has had either added
sugar or added sweetener,
and often pectin to make it sort
of a solid, clear, spreadable
preserve.
And so preserve is sort of
just the all-purpose word.
And then also,
preserve is often used
to refer to sort of
bigger pieces of fruit
in syrup that isn't
quite as set as jam.
Jam is a whole
fruit preserve that
can either have
additional pectin or not,
but is sort of fruit
and syrup all together.
And then so the preserve is
sort of this all-purpose term.
And then you've
got a fruit butter,
which is a fruit puree
that has been cooked
down slowly and over low
heat over time, so that you
concentrate the
fiber in the fruit.
You cook out the water, you
concentrate the sweetness.
I'm sure everybody's had
apple butter in the past.
You can do that with any fruit.
So I've done blueberry butters,
and strawberry butters.
Sweet cherry butter
is awfully good.
And so you can do that with
a lot different fruits.
Jelly, jam, preserve, butter.
Curd.
Fruit curds are a
fruit juice preserve
that's set up with egg yolk and
then has butter added to it.
So it's a very
rich, spreadable--
I'm just kind of finding all
the different terms for you now.
AUDIENCE: Compote.
MARISA MCCLELLAN: Compote.
That's a good one.
So compote is a less sweetened,
typically in a thin syrup,
fruit that's been cooked down.
It's not going to have as much
sugar, honey, or whatever.
It's going to be-- and
often, they're made quickly.
So often, compotes
are just like,
oh, I have this
peach and this plum
and these few cherries
that need to be used up.
Let me just cook them
down, and then we'll
put them over oatmeal is kind
of compote's driving force.
A conserve is a jam that has
either citrus peel, or nuts,
or dried fruit added to it.
Ooh, a chutney.
Chutneys are sort
of like a jam, only
it's a sweet and
savory preserve.
So it's like fruit, and sugar,
and vinegar, and spices,
and onions, or garlic,
things like that.
And so it's really got both the
sweet and the savory element
in one jar.
Just to note, if you ever make
chutneys, and you open the jar,
and you find that it's really
overpoweringly vinegary,
I find that chutney
has a lot in common
with wine in terms of
its needs to breathe
after you've opened the jar.
Because you've made the chutney,
you've slapped the lid on it,
you processed it.
And then it sort of has
been just hanging out.
And it needs a
little bit of time
to release some of that vinegar.
I just realized, I need to
get my vanilla bean in here
as things simmer away.
Fresh vanilla beans
are a really great way
to add a lot of flavor to jams.
They can be really expensive
if you just buy them
by the one or the two
at the grocery store.
I tend to buy them in bulk.
I am a little obsessive
about this sort of thing.
But anybody can
buy them in bulk.
You don't have to just
be a preserver to do it.
And a pound of grade B
vanilla beans are about $55.
So when you buy them
at the grocery store,
you'll pay $10 or
$20 for two beans.
And if you buy them in
bulk, you'll spend $55,
you'll get 150 to 180 beans.
And so if you're interested
in adding vanilla bean
to your pantry, it's always
fun to go in with a friend
and buy, like, a half pound
or a pound, and split them up.
And then you can do cool stuff
like make your own vanilla
extract, or vanilla finishing
salts, or flavored sugars,
and stuff like that.
So it's a fun, little
pantry addition
if you find yourself loving
the flavor of fresh vanilla
bean in your preserves.
And all I did was I split the
bean down the center, I exposed
the two, I exposed the interior.
And then I just used
the flat of my knife
to scrape those seeds out.
And then I added the
seeds to the pan.
And now I'm also going to
drop the pod into the pan
in order to extract as much
flavor from it as possible.
I always tell people to
add the seeds to the pan,
because I had a friend
email me one day and say,
I made your preserve, I
made your pear vanilla jam,
and you didn't
tell me what to do
once I scraped the vanilla bean.
So I threw away the
scrapings, and I just
popped the pod into the pan.
And it broke my heart,
because the seeds
are where all the goodness is.
Like, you get some
flavor from the pod too.
But I just like to make
sure everybody knows.
You're going to scrape
those seeds out,
and you're going to
add them to the pan.
So let's take a look
at how this is looking.
One of my favorite ways to
tell whether jam is finished
is by looking at the
droplets on a spatula to see,
is it thickening up?
Because what this does
is, as it thickens,
it's going to change
consistency as it cools down.
So when you run your
spatula through and then
hold up the droplets, it's
going to cool down rapidly,
this little sample that
you've taken out of the pan.
And so you can look and see,
do I have thick droplets?
Do they look thick?
Do they have a wide base that
are hanging onto the spatula
as I wiggle it?
This one's not there yet.
But it's nice to set
a baseline and look
at the droplets over
the time that it's
cooking to see how
it's setting up.
Another way-- and you
can't really see this,
but I'm going to
explain it to you--
is that one of the nice things
about making this in a skillet
is that you can tell that it's
thickening up as you stir,
because when you
pull a line through,
as it gets closer to being
done, that space will stay open.
And so you can very easily tell.
You'll be able to kind
of sculpt it in the pan.
And so as it continues
to cook, you'll
be able to see it kind
of thicken up in the pan.
AUDIENCE: How long
does the vanilla bean
stay for in the cabinet?
MARISA MCCLELLAN: Oh,
how long in the cabinet?
I am working through
a batch that I
bought almost two years ago.
And what I do is I triple
wrap them in plastic,
so I have three Ziploc
bags inside of each other.
And I just keep them in a cool--
like in the corner of a kitchen
cabinet.
They don't need to be in the
refrigerator or the freezer.
And they really last awhile.
And if they do harden
up, you can just
put them in some warm water
for a minute or two before you
use them.
And it's enough to
sort of re-plump it.
And then you can get
good flavor out of it.
Yeah.
They give a lot.
And the nice thing, too, is
that once this jam is finished
cooking, we can actually take
that vanilla bean out, rinse it
off, dry it off,
and then you could
let it sit on
your-- let it cool,
or dry on your counter
for a day or so.
And then put it
in a jar of sugar,
and it will still be able
to flavor that sugar.
If you're making some
homemade vanilla extract,
you can drop that pod that
has been cooked and scraped,
and it'll still add flavor
to the vanilla extract.
So you can get a
lot out of them.
Can you guys smell this?
Are you getting
the smell of this?
Shoot.
It smells really good right
here, let me just tell you.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
Oh.
Does someone have a question?
All right.
So another way that you can
tell the jam is getting near
to its done point
is that as you stir,
it's going to sizzle
a little bit more
frantically as you stir it.
And so I always try to
say to people that it's
going to tell you
both visually, it's
going to tell you as
the smell, the aroma
get stronger, that
it's almost done.
And it's going to get glossier,
and you're going to hear it.
You're going to
hear that sizzle.
So it's talking to you.
The pan is talking to you.
So just as long as
you know the language,
you're going to be able to
know that your jam is done.
So I'm going to be
quiet for a second
now and stir, and see if you
guys can hear the sizzle.
Did you hear that?
So that's an indication that
the temperature is hotter,
that the jam, physically, is
hotter than 212 degrees now.
And I'm cooking at high.
The name of the game
is evaporation, right?
So you want to have your
temperature up as high,
cook as hot and fast
as you possibly can
without burning yourself
and without burning the jam.
I don't want you to hurt
yourself when you make this.
So if you need to sacrifice
and have a couple minutes
longer cooking time
to prevent yourself
from getting a second degree
burn from splashing jam
on your arm, please turn
the temperature down.
But do try to keep it up as high
as you can manage and control
without doing harm to yourself.
So let's talk a little bit
about the canning process
now, because that's really
what we're here for, right?
You don't want to
just hear about jam,
you want to hear about canning.
So this is my canning
pot for today.
And this is my teeny, tiny
small-batch canning pot.
I use it at home a lot.
It's really handy.
It's not designed for canning,
but it works really well
for canning.
This pot's called
the 4th Burner pot.
And what I really like about it
is that it's tall and narrow,
so you can stack a
couple jars inside of it.
And here, I'll show you what
I have in here right now.
I just have two of these
little wide-mouth half
pints stacked one on
top of each other.
And this batch is going
to make probably enough
to fill these jars with
a little bit left over,
so that we can taste
when we're all done.
Although, I didn't bring
anything to taste on.
We'll cross that bridge
when we get there.
There's snacks everywhere.
I'm sure we can find a cracker.
So what I like about
this pot, the reason
it's such a good
pot for canning is
that it comes fitted
with this little rack.
Any time you can,
you want to make sure
that you are-- any pot
can be a canning pot.
You just need to
make sure that it
has a rack in it to ensure
that the jars are elevated off
the bottom of the pot, so
that the water can circulate,
and so that they
don't rattle and break
on the bottom of the pot.
Because you know how
when water boils,
the little bubbles originate
from the bottom of the pan,
and they move upwards
with increasing force.
And so when they
bubble and boil up,
they can actually rattle those
jars enough to break them.
And so you just want
to have something
at the bottom of the pot.
When you're dong larger
batches, you a silicone trivet
will work.
This is my favorite sort of
modified canning rack, modified
in the sense that I drop
it in the bottom of the pot
and call it a canning rack.
It's a silicone trivet.
It's called the blossom trivet.
They sell it on Amazon.
If you go looking for one,
click through all the colors
before you buy it, because
they vary in price, $3 or $4,
depending on what color you get.
So the algorithm.
Who knows?
So depending on whether you
want black or pink or orange,
you might pay $3
or $4 more or less.
But orange was the cheapest
the last time I bought it,
so that's why I
have an orange one.
Oops, we're getting a
little sticking here.
All right.
I'm going to stir
and pay attention
to this for just a moment.
All right.
Let's look at our
droplets one more time,
and then I'll talk about
the canning process.
So you see how much
thicker they've
gotten in just a couple
minutes of cooking?
That sugar is concentrating.
The water is cooking out.
We're getting a lot of
steam happening here.
And I would say in just
another two or three minutes,
this is going to be
done, which is great.
See?
It doesn't take all
day to make jam.
It's very nice.
We'll talk a little
bit about pickles,
too, because pickles are another
one where people are selling
us, sort off-- you
know, you buy a $12 jar
of pickles or a $15 or
$20 jar of pickles--
it cost them $2 to
make those pickles.
You can do that at home.
Very easy, very delicious.
There's nothing better
than a homemade pickle.
But so let's talk about
the canning process.
Let me turn this
down a little bit.
So any pot can be a
canning pot as long
as it's tall enough to
hold a rack at the bottom,
have the jars fully
submerged in water,
have a little bit of water
covering them at the top,
and then have some room at
the top of the pot to boil.
So a stainless steel stockpot,
it can be a great canning pot.
If you have a pasta
pot with an insert,
that's a really
good canning pot.
This 4th Burner pot,
an asparagus pot,
which is sort of a less
fancy 4th Burner pot.
Whatever you have,
you can make it
work as long as the
pot is tall enough
to fully submerge the jar.
So I've heated up the jars.
I brought this pot to a boil
before I cooked the jam.
And then they've just been
hanging out, sitting here.
They don't have to be
sterilised before we
put the jam in the
jars, because we're
going to boil the jars once
they're full for 10 minutes.
And if you boil something
for 10 minutes or longer,
that is your sterilization step.
So you don't have to
worry that everything
has to be perfectly,
meticulously immaculate.
All we need is for it
to be clean and hot when
we put the finished jam in it.
And we're going
to wipe the rims,
put the lids and
rings on the jars,
and put them back in the water.
One thing is that when we
put the jam in the jars,
we always want to make sure
to leave some head space.
And head space is simply
the amount of space
to leave from the
top of the product,
so how much it's filled
up, to the top of the jar.
And you typically
want about-- let
me get it turned
to the right place.
You want about half an inch.
And the reason for that
is that that half an inch
of head space, that oxygen
that you trap in the jar,
is going to create the seal.
Because when you
fill up these jars,
you're going to fill them up so
that the product is somewhere
in between where the
continuous thread overlaps.
So every mason jar has
a continuous thread.
And then there's a
point where it overlaps.
You just want your
product to be somewhere
in between the top
and the bottom thread.
You've trapped that
oxygen in there.
And when you put the rings
on, you tighten them enough,
so that they meet resistance,
they're fully on there.
But you don't
tighten them so much
that the oxygen can't escape.
Because when we put the
full jars back in the water
and we apply heat
to it, that oxygen
that we've trapped
in that head space
is going to start to
vent as we boil the jars,
because the heat makes
the oxygen agitate,
and move around,
and exit the jars.
And so throughout
the boiling process--
you guys are all
science-y people,
and I'm probably explaining this
terribly for science-y people.
But it's basically,
they're venting.
The jars are venting
throughout the boiling process,
so that when we take
them out, everything
that had been expanding
during the boiling process
starts to contract.
And as it contracts,
you form a vacuum.
And as that vacuum
forms-- because there's
nothing there to hold
that space anymore,
because we vented all the
oxygen out that was there
before-- that lid pulls down.
And it pulls down
in a way where you
create a natural vacuum
that is then backed up
by the sealing
compound on the lid.
And so these lids
are in the water,
because I want to
soften this rubber
ring, this sealing compound.
It'll soften continually
throughout the boiling process.
And then when we
take those jars out
and that vacuum
starts to pull, it's
going to pull this lid in
tighter and tighter contact
with the rim of that jar.
And then as the
jars are cooling,
the sealing compound hardens.
So it's sort of a double seal.
You've got a natural
vacuum backed up
by this hardening
sealing compound.
I always like to say that
it's like when you were a kid
and you put a cup on your
face, over your mouth,
and you sucked
in, and sucked in,
and sucked in until the
cup stuck to your face.
That's basically what's
happening in the jar.
And then it's as if someone
put, like, super glue on the cup
without you knowing it,
and you sucked it in,
and it stuck to your face,
not that anyone would do that.
It's sort of a ridiculous
analogy, I know.
But that's kind of-- if you
want to think about sort
of a real-life scenario of
how the vacuum is forming
and what's backing it up, that's
kind of what's happening there.
So let's look at our jam.
I'm going to turn
this all the way up.
Did I kill my-- I think
I killed the-- yeah.
Killed the heat.
So it's almost there.
I'm just going to bring it
back up to an active boil
for just a second more.
It's still got this little--
once it sits in the pan,
it spreads a little bit
more than I like it to,
and it's got little bits
of water around the edges.
So I just want to cook
that last bit of water
out and make sure that it's
going be nice and thick.
AUDIENCE: You never use
frozen fruits, right?
MARISA MCCLELLAN: You
can use frozen fruits.
When you freeze fruit,
you take those cells,
every little cell in the fruit.
And when you freeze it, the
water inside those cells
expands, and it bursts
all the cell walls.
And so then when it defrosts,
it releases its liquid,
and it's not going to have
as much pectin content,
because you've
sort of bust open--
you've broken down that pectin
in the cell walls a little bit.
So you're going to have to
work a little bit harder
to get frozen fruit to
come to a set point,
because if I'm making
jam with frozen fruit,
I always make sure
to use some pectin,
because you're going to
need a little pectin boost,
because you've sort of
stressed the natural pectin
in the fruit.
But you certainly can do it.
AUDIENCE: What did you use to
pull the lid out of the water?
MARISA MCCLELLAN: This
is called the lid wand.
It's a plastic stick
with a magnet on the end.
And it is the best
tool ever, because you
can move your lids in
and out of the water
without burning yourself.
When it comes to
canning, there are really
three tools that I recommend
as sort of must-haves.
This is pretty handy,
and it costs, like, $3.
So you know.
AUDIENCE: For all colors?
[LAUGHTER]
MARISA MCCLELLAN: Yes.
These days, I see it mostly
in fluorescent green.
But if you look hard, you
could still get the blue ones.
So you want a lid
lifter, a jar lifter,
and then a wide-mouth funnel.
And those are really your
three pieces of equipment
that you really want to have.
You want a canning
rack, but you don't
have to even have this guy.
If you have a round
cake cooling rack,
like a stainless steel
that can be your canning rack.
You can even drop a kitchen
towel in the bottom of your pot
and call that your canning
rack, because it's essentially
padding the jars at
the bottom and allowing
some of the heat to circulate.
All right.
So we hear all that sizzling.
That says to me that
this jam is done.
There's not as much water
coming out at the edges.
And the bits of
fruit-- like, there's
not as much distinct
fruit pieces,
which is what you want to see.
I like a fairly chunky jam.
I don't want it to
be perfectly smooth,
but you want the fruit
to have broken down.
And look at how thick it is
now that it's on the spatula.
That's what you want to see.
All right.
We're going to
call this guy done.
One little tip is to always
stir your jam for a minute
or two after you've turned
off the heat-- not a minute.
You know, 15
seconds, 30 seconds.
Basically, what this does is
it helps let that last steam
escape, and it tightens
it up just a bit more.
And you're just going to get
a slightly better texture.
You can also tell
that it's done.
Here, I'm going to
tilt this a little bit.
Can you see how nice and thick?
And when I pull the
spatula through,
that that space stays open?
That's what you're looking for.
So the reason I used a
stainless steel pan today
and I asked them to find me
one, as opposed to aluminum,
is when you're making
jam, you really
want to use a nonreactive metal.
You either want enamel, cast
iron, or stainless steel,
or anodized aluminum.
Because if you use a bare
aluminum pan, or a bare cast
iron pan, you can
leach a metallic flavor
into your finished preserve.
So aluminum and cast
iron are reactive metals.
And so they react with acids,
and they release a little bit
of themselves into
whatever you're
cooking in that pan,
which is great sometimes
if you're someone
who's iron deficient
and wants to get a little
extra iron into your diet.
You can use a cast iron pan.
But with preserves, you end
up leaching a metallic flavor
that doesn't ever go away.
And about once a summer,
I hear from someone
who writes that they have
made 15 pints of salsa
in a giant aluminum pot.
They cooked it for
a couple of hours,
and now it tastes like
they're licking aluminum foil.
And they ask me
what they can do.
And unfortunately,
there's nothing
you can do in that scenario.
You either have to get
used to the taste of tin,
or you have to throw
the salsa away.
And it's really heartbreaking
for people who spent a day
and a half making a batch of
salsa to hear that it cannot be
eaten.
So you really want to look for
stainless steel or enamel cast
iron, or anodized aluminum.
I tend to stay
away from nonstick
when I'm making preserves
simply because I'm
cooking at a fairly
high temperature.
And nonstick doesn't do
well at high temperatures.
It starts to break down.
It's just not good for the pan.
So if you want to maintain
the quality of your nonstick,
cooking it over high
heat for 10 or 15 minutes
isn't going to be the
best way to do it.
So I recommend something where
you can cook the heck out
of it, and nothing's
going to happen.
All right.
So we're going to pour
the jam into the jars
with our wide-mouth funnel.
Sometimes I do this
blind, looking over
the top of the pan,
and I'm not going
to do that today, because
we're recording this,
and no one needs to see me pour
jam all over the counter top
here.
So nice color, right?
It's kind of a
little bit peachy.
You can see how
pretty this would
be if you had, like, a pure
yellow plum, too, because it
would be, like, translucently
yellow and perfect.
But I like it like this, too.
All right.
So our jars are filled.
I just like to give
them a little wiggle.
They could both
probably use, like,
one more tablespoon
of jam, but I
want to leave us enough to eat.
So I'm not going to
top them off quite as
much as I might if I
was doing this at home.
And then I'm going
to grab my lids.
Actually, that's a lie.
I'm going to grab a
paper towel, and I'm
going to wipe the
rims just to make sure
that there's nothing
on there that
could prevent a good
seal from forming.
All right.
So lid one.
And you always want to place the
lids independent of the rings,
just so that you
know that you're
getting the sealing
compound in direct contact
with the whole of
the rim of the jar.
If you place them
with the rings,
if you have them
all attached, you're
just not getting that
perfect placement.
And I didn't sterilize these.
I didn't even heat them up.
It's really hard to screw a
ring on if it's piping hot.
And there's really no
reason, because they're
going to be in the pot with
the jars for the 10 minutes.
So it'll be fine.
So again, you just turn it
till it meets resistance.
You don't have to, like,
go like that with it.
You just want to turn it so
that the oxygen can escape
and that you can
get a good seal.
And I promise, the
oxygen will leave.
The water won't go in.
You can trust me.
It's just not going to happen.
Because the force of the
oxygen is going to be, sort of,
constantly venting throughout.
So it prevents any
water from leaching in.
And I am stacking these.
You can stack your jars.
That sort of blows the mind of
some people when they can on
occasion.
They're like, what,
you can stack the jars?
You can stack the jars.
No big deal.
All right.
So we're going to just
bring this up to a boil,
boil it for 10 minutes.
And at 10 minutes-- and
so I don't set the timer
until it hits a
full rolling boil.
Once it's at a
full, rolling boil,
that's the point at
which we set the timer.
I'm also just going to make
a little public service
announcement right now.
And no shame if
you've done this.
But this is the end
of the jar lifter
that you put on the jars,
and this is the handle.
I've often seen people
use them upside down.
And you don't get
nearly as secure a grip
if you're trying to grip on the
jar with the handle portion.
Do you guys know
the website Food52?
Anybody?
A few.
I'm seeing a few nods.
They have a picture
on their website--
or at least they
did last summer.
They were selling
canning tools, and they
were using, in the picture,
the jar lifter the wrong way.
And so what can you do?
But for you at home,
when you go home and can,
make sure you do
it so that you're
going to get the best,
most secure grip.
Because otherwise you're
going to feel really insecure
as you lift piping hot jars
in and out of boiling water.
And no one needs that extra
stress in their lives.
So yeah.
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I noticed you didn't
try to get out the air bubbles.
Is that not really
an issue for jam?
MARISA MCCLELLAN: It's
really not an issue for jam.
Anytime you make
jam, it's just kind
of going to flow into the jars.
And if it's a
really thick jam, I
might run a chopstick around
the inside of the jar.
But most of the time I
only try to really-- I'm
active about getting
the air bubbles out
if I'm making, like, pickles or
something that's really thick.
So let's talk about pickles
a little bit, shall we?
So basic pickles.
The basic ratio for
pickles-- anytime you
want to pickle anything, it
is one part vinegar, one part
water, and one tablespoon
of a finely milled salt
per cup of vinegar you're using.
And that can be your pickle
brine for everything.
And then with that
ratio, you can
pickle green beans, cucumbers,
okra, broccoli, cauliflower,
Brussels sprouts.
What else do you want to pickle?
AUDIENCE: Turnips.
MARISA MCCLELLAN: Turnips.
You could do a
thinly sliced turnip.
Some thinly sliced radish.
AUDIENCE: Watermelon rind.
MARISA MCCLELLAN:
Watermelon rind's
going to be a little different,
because you add sugar to it,
but it's basically the same.
You're going to use a little
less water and a little bit
more sugar, because you want
to create more of a syrup
and you want it to
be really flavorful.
But yeah, watermelon rind
is a delicious pickle.
I'm writing a new
book right now, too.
This just came out, but
I'm writing a new book
about naturally
sweetened preserves, too.
So I'm doing a honey-sweetened
watermelon rind
pickle in that book, which
so far, it is amazingly good.
So that's a fun pickle.
Yeah.
So basically, you take
that same standard ratio,
you put your spices at
the bottom of the jar.
So for, like, a
garlic dill pickle,
a couple of garlic cloves, a
teaspoon or two of dill seed.
You want to you use dill
seed and not dill weed,
because the dill seed is going
to hold up better over time.
Dill weed sort of
breaks down, and it
makes your pickling
brine kind of murky.
And one of the ways where
we tell whether something's
gone wrong with a
preserve is how it looks.
And so if your brine changes--
if it goes opaque, and changes
a little bit of color,
that's an indication
that something might be
going wrong with the jar.
Often, if you've
used dill seed, it's
just that the dill seed is sort
of dissolving into the vinegar.
But it gives you sort
of that peace of mind
knowing that you're not having
something that's going wrong.
So put your spices at
the bottom of the jars,
pack those vegetables
in pretty tightly,
and then pour the brine on top.
I don't have a jar anymore, but
when I have a full pickle jar,
I just tap it on
the counter first
to help release any
trapped air bubbles.
And then you go around
with either a wooden
or a plastic
chopstick, or a really
kind of long, narrow
silicon or rubber spatula,
and help release
the air bubbles.
The reason you want to
release those air bubbles
is that if you trap air bubbles
inside of a canning jar,
the same thing is going
to happen to those air
bubbles that are trapped
throughout the product that
happened to the air that
you leave in the head
space of the jar, right?
So as you heat the jars, the
oxygen's going to agitate,
it's going to try
to leave the jar.
But if you've got
these air bubbles down
inside the jar, what
ends up happening
is that they push brine
out, or liquid out,
as they try to escape the jar.
And so if you've
ever canned pickles
or, like, a thick--
like, a fruit preserve,
like peach halves, you'll
often have liquid loss.
It's called
siphoning in canning.
I don't know why, but
that's what they mean?
Why can't we just call
it liquid loss, really?
Every niche has its
vocabulary, right?
That's one of the
canning vocabulary words.
So then you end
up with jars where
you've lost an inch
or two of liquid.
And it's not bad in
terms of it's not
going to make you sick,
but the stuff that's
not submerged in the
brine, or the syrup,
or whatever canning
medium you've put it in,
it's going to discolor
and lose quality faster.
And so by bubbling those jars
you prevent the liquid loss,
and so you make a
product that's going
to last longer on the shelf.
Let's talk a little bit
about what can go bad,
or what can go wrong.
So with these high-acid
preserves-- and we're boiling,
so I'm going to set
a timer real quick.
With these high-acid
preserves, you're
never going to have botulism.
But things can go
wrong on occasion.
But you're always going
to be able to see them
or smell them immediately upon
opening the jar.So you're never
going to accidentally eat
something that is bad,
because you're
going to look at it
and go, huh, I don't
want to eat that.
You're going to
open a jar, and it
will have changed
color dramatically.
Or it will be bubbling, which is
an indication of fermentation.
It'll smell boozy and
not in a good way.
It will smell bad.
Something will be wrong.
And you'll look at it and
think, huh, this is not right.
Let me get rid of this.
It's not going to be unsafe.
It's something you can
put in a compost bin
or down the garbage
disposal or in the trash.
It's not a hazard.
But it's just something
you don't want to eat.
And so you make sure that you
notice, you pay attention.
You don't ever open a
jar and sort of start
to eat it without looking
at it for just a minute.
You know, you might
have a jam emergency
and be like, I
need jam right now.
Well, just give
that jam a once over
before you start pouring it
into your yogurt or whatever.
So another indication
the jar has gone bad
is that the seal will go bad.
Because what happens
is if things ferment
or they start to develop some
sort of bacterial or yeast
infection, or whatever,
that off-gasses.
That process of
that microorganism
growing off gases,
and that off-gassing
will pressure up against
the lid and break the seal.
And so that's why,
you know, it's
like if you ever hear the
warning to not eat bulging tin
cans from the grocery
store, the same thing goes.
Because in the
grocery store, there's
no way for that
can to break open
unless something truly
disastrous is happening inside.
But for a mason jar,
that off-gassing
is going to produce enough
force to break the seal.
And so you're going to know,
when you open that jar,
if the lid comes off too
easily, that it's not something
you want to eat.
That's really it for that
kind of safety thing.
As far storage goes,
cool, dark place.
Keep it out of sunlight.
I live, again, high-rise.
I don't have a
basement, I don't have
any sort of natural, good
place to store preserves.
So I have some under my
couch and some under my bed.
And I have a coat closet
that's sort of double depth.
And so you spread the coats, and
its a wall of pickles and jams.
And it works out quite well.
But because sunlight
is the enemy,
it's going to start to
discolor your preserves.
And as they discolor,
they're going
to sort of lose
flavor and texture.
And so you just want
to keep them out
of sunlight if possible.
AUDIENCE: Is it
better in the fridge?
MARISA MCCLELLAN: Well, once
you've done the processing,
it's shelf-stable, so
it doesn't have to be.
Like, if that's your only
good place to store it
and you don't have anything
else in your refrigerator,
sure, go for it.
But the nice thing about
making jams and stuff
like this, for me, is
that-- and that's why I can
these small batches is that
I have a small refrigerator.
And if I put everything I make
over the course of the summer
and fall in the
refrigerator, there's
not room for anything else.
And my husband
doesn't like fruit,
and he doesn't
really like pickles.
And so, um-- I know.
He has many other
fine qualities.
[LAUGHTER]
MARISA MCCLELLAN: He finds our
refrigerator a little bit scary
on a regular basis.
And I'm a food writer.
There's a lot of stuff
happening in my kitchen.
And so if I had a refrigerator
that was entirely full of jars,
he would never open it,
and he wouldn't starve,
but he would not eat at home.
And so we like to
make sure that he
can use the refrigerator
whenever possible.
So that's why.
But yeah, I mean, if that's
your best space for it,
then that's fine, too.
AUDIENCE: Once you open a
jar, how long is it good?
MARISA MCCLELLAN: Like a
jam with this much sugar--
I mean, this isn't
tons and tons of sugar,
but this is a ratio
of about two to one.
This jam is going
to last for months
open in the refrigerator.
If you make something
that's really low in sugar--
because sugar is a preservative,
the less sugar that's
in a product, the less
time it's going to last.
And when it goes bad,
it'll either, again, will
start to ferment in the
fridge a little bit,
like, get a little fizzy,
or it'll start to grow mold.
A month or more.
Almost always.
And pickles, pickles
last forever.
You know, the thing
to do is to make
sure you're using sort
of good jar hygiene.
So anytime you go
into a jar of jam,
or chutney, or pickles, or
whatever, use a clean utensil,
so that you're not introducing
any sort of potential bacteria
or foreign funk to the jar,
so that it stays good longer.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How long
does something
last once it's jarred?
MARISA MCCLELLAN: So
the USDA always says
to use your home preserved
food for best quality
within a calendar year.
But there's no, like,
alarm bell that's
going off on day 366 or 367.
It's just that as things
age, they decline in quality.
But I have found that with
a jam like this, three years
is, like-- by year
three, it's going
to start to lose its
texture a little bit
and be a little bit funny.
But I always think of it--
I don't give something away
that is older than two years.
But within the first
two years, it's still
going to be delicious, it's
still going to be safe,
it's going to give
someone a good, long time.
And that's about what
they use in terms
of commercial production, too.
Like if you buy something
at a grocery store
or at a farmer's
market, about two years
is how far out they're
putting their best-by date.
Any other questions?
Do you guys want
to taste some jam?
All right.
Awesome.
So I think Chris went in
search of things to put jam on.
AUDIENCE: Pretzels and chips.
MARISA MCCLELLAN: Perfect.
AUDIENCE: They're kind
of unflavored, so.
MARISA MCCLELLAN: That works.
Awesome.
So thank you guys
for coming today.
This was really fun.
I hope you had a good time.
This lovely lady in
the back has books.
And if you want to buy one, I'd
be happy to sign it for you.
I'll personalize it
any way you want,
and I will correct the typos,
because there are a few.
And yeah.
So thank you.
My name's Marisa.
My website is
foodinjars.com And I
hope that you all
make something.
So thanks.
[APPLAUSE]